The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We continue
this wee, next week,
with our conversation-- it's
really our final conversation--
about the genre forms that are
at the center of the Hollywood
era with a consideration
of the Western.
And that perhaps we should
begin by acknowledging
how central the
Western is as a movie
form in the history
of American cinema.
Before the advent of
television in the late '40s--
the first American television
broadcast was 1946.
And we can say the
television is actually
established is a social
experience in American life
certainly by the late '40s,
by let's say 1949 or 1950.
And it's through the
'50s that television
spreads through the society and
begins to supplant the movies.
So that before
television, let's say
that before 1950,
nearly 30% percent
of every movie made
in the United States
was a Western all the way
through the Hollywood era.
And in fact, in the silent
era, as I will describe briefly
again this evening when I
do a kind of mini history
of the Western movie,
even in the silent era,
it's a central form.
And even after the 1950s, even
after the advent of television,
nearly half of
all movies that we
might identify as set in the
past, as historical movies,
were Westerns.
And of course, as
I suggested when
I talked about the
musical, the Western
can be understood along with the
musical as a uniquely American
form, even though
at a certain point
in the mid and late '1960s,
certain gifted Italian
directors begin to
take over the Western
and darken it and throw a
kind of European cynicism
into the tradition
of the Western.
By that time, the Western
genre evolved and transformed
in ways that made this cynicism
not completely unique, not
totally European, because a
kind of subversive perspective
had begun to enter the American
version of the Western as well.
Nonetheless, the
Western form underwent
profound transformations.
And it's those
transformations that I
want to briefly to talk about
here in an introductory way.
And I'll return to
that sort of what
we might call the
trajectory or the career
of the Western briefly this
evening when I introduce
some comments I want
to make about John Ford
and about his classic Western,
the film we're watching
tonight, "The Searchers."
I want to talk a
little bit more,
not only about the Western,
but about why the Western might
be seen as being the
central American form,
why it is so central not only to
the History of American cinema,
but in a certain sense,
central to the cultural history
of American society.
One way to see
this is to reframe
the idea I've been suggesting
all through the term
this notion that
at a certain point,
the movies became a form
of central storytelling
in the society, the
form of storytelling
that more Americans
than any other form
participated in and
experienced, a form that I've
come to label
consensus narrative,
a kind of story system that
appeals across social barriers
and across age that intends
in some sense to express what
might be called the dominant
or the central values
of a society.
We talked about this idea--
I've talked about this idea
already at some
length and I don't
want to spend too
much time on it here.
But I want to complicate
those ideas one more
time by reminding you that one
way to think about or one way
to frame this notion that the
movies and the Western form
in particular embody this
notion of a story form that
tends to reach the whole
society or to speak
for the whole
society or to embody
the central values
of the whole society
is one way of understanding
the implications of that
is to recognize, first of all,
that the Hollywood system which
is so committed to forms
of genre representation
is particularly served by the
principles of repetition that
are inherent in the conventions
that surround the Western.
Even the Western-- the
content of Westerns
or the attitudes
within Westerns might
undergo great transformations,
the basic formulas
remain recognizable
from the earliest days.
We think about the costumes, the
horses, the guns, and so forth,
and even certain basic
plots and subplots that
keep returning in the Western.
As with the musical,
the genre is so robust
that it has many
sort of some sub
within it so that one
can talk about Westerns
that involve battles between
sheep herders and ranchers.
Or one can talk
about the Westerns
that are so focused
on the laying
of the transcontinental
railroad.
Or one could focus on
Westerns that focus
on the conflict between
white settlers and Indians.
Now, many Westerns combine
a number of these elements.
And there are other sub
genres we could describe.
The very fact that there
are these sub genres
is a measure of how
robust the system became.
And one way to think, therefore,
about this idea that I've
labeled, consensus
narrative, or another way
to think about what I've
earlier in the course
called the cultural
work of the movies
or the cultural, the
anthropological job,
that genre forms in general
during the Hollywood era
perform, is to recognize
that we can understand
the specific genre
as a distilled
instance of the larger
process of the movies,
right, as a smaller
clarifying instance,
we can understand
in a certain sense
as a forum, a space
of conversation,
a space of discourse in
which the culture engages
in a kind of ongoing
conversation.
You remember the terms
I used earlier borrowing
from the English critic
Raymond Williams.
I said that we can understand
that these genre reforms
or these consensus forms
could be said to mobilize
three different
strains of attitude--
an emergent, a dominant, and
a traditional set of voices--
and that one of the
explanations for why
genre texts and the
Hollywood movie specifically
and the Western in particular
are often so conflicted
or divided is precisely
that they embody
or incorporate
some attitudes that
are traditional and old
fashioned, some attitudes that
are emerging and challenge
traditional ideas,
and also what we might
central or dominant values,
and that not every text
will balance those elements
in exactly the same way.
The second point about
this is to recognize
that one of the beauties of
genre, one of the reasons
they serve such a fundamental
cultural or anthropological
function in a
society, is precisely
that they go on forever,
that in other words
we can think of genre forms as
a kind of ongoing continuing
conversation centered
on the same formats
and the same conventions.
And if the genre is stable
and if the society produces
these genre forms over
decades, the genre
form itself becomes a
mirror in which we can see
reflected the changing values
and assumptions of the culture.
Now, this might be true of
any kind of a particular genre
form in any medium.
But the reason it has
special force when
we're talking about the
movies in the 20th century
in the United
States is precisely
because the form is so
central to the society,
because so much of the
society participates in it.
So the picture of
the society that
is the ambivalent and conflicted
picture of the society that
emerges from studying
these genre forms
is likely to be far more
illuminating about the larger
culture than, let's say, a study
of a cultural form, let's say,
like opera.
Not that the opera isn't worth
studying and doesn't reflect
certain cultural values too,
but because the opera appeals
to a particular
subculture, the values
are going to be narrower.
The kinds of assumptions
the people writing opera
and attending opera make about
the larger culture and about
aesthetic experience
are profoundly
different from the
much more dispersed
and democratic attitudes
and accessible notions
that animate the create
of a consensus form,
of a form that's trying to
reach the whole of a culture.
So this is a way
of reminding you
of what we might call
the sociological and
anthropological importance
of the study of popular forms
in general and of
American movies
in particular, the Western
genre even more especially.
We can think, therefore,
of the Western almost
as a form of kind of national
theater, a kind of repertory
company in which the same
relatively small number,
recognizably small number,
of actors and actresses,
of directors and other sub
specialists whose names are
never remembered, collaborate
to create the film.
We can think of the
movies as embodying,
in a certain sense,
what I'm calling
the theater of a nation.
And I put the phrase
in quotation marks
not because it's a fancy
phrase, but because I
want to call
attention to the fact
that I'm actually
borrowing a phrase
from a great literary
historian who
wrote a book about
Shakespeare's audience
and about Shakespeare's plays
and about the public theater
of Shakespeare's day and
called that theater the theater
of a nation.
And in a certain sense, we could
say that the Hollywood system
was a similar kind of theater.
It doesn't from this
that every text created
there is a noble work of art.
And it's very
important to recognize
that the distinction
I'm making between
and anthropological
perspective and an artistic one
must hold here.
And it's another reason
for emphasizing this.
Because the fact
of the matter is
it's very hard in
a course like this,
especially-- because some of
these films are so wonderful,
my own enthusiasm
encourages you to like them
and I want you to like them.
Nonetheless, it's very
important to recognize
that I'm not trying to tell
you a merely triumphalist story
about how magnificently
American movies began
to sort of realize
their possibilities
and dramatize experience.
Because in a certain
fundamental sense,
these consensus values are
not necessarily noble ones.
And the western is a
particularly clear instance
of this.
And what I'm talking
about in a certain sense
is the extent to which
these genre reforms carry
the lies, the prejudices, the
nasty qualities of a society
as well as their
ideals and values.
And we can feel those
elements, even though the films
themselves want to
tell uplifting stories,
the values embedded in them may
not be so attractive at all.
And the Western is a
particularly clear instance
of this-- a reminder,
again, that we don't just
look at films for
aesthetic satisfaction.
We don't just look
at films for-- we
don't need to just look at
films for mere enjoyment.
They are anthropological
artifacts
of the greatest importance
exactly because they existed
at such a central, at such a
fundamental space in the larger
society.
Why would the Western--
why would the Western
be such a central form?
Why, in some sense, could
we think of the movies,
with its vast,
wide, giant screen,
as the ultimate
destiny of the Western?
I think one explanation for
the power of the Western film,
because there were
Western stories
and other Western formats
before the advent of film--
and I'll talk about
them in a moment.
Why would the film be such a
decisive space for the Western?
And I think if you think
about it for a moment,
you'll recognize instantly
why that is the case.
The format of the
movies is particularly
conducive to the sense of
grandeur and largeness,
spaciousness, that's
characteristic of Western
spaces and of the parables
of heroism and social create,
society creation,
so the equation
of a particular culture or
environment in the wilderness,
the establishment of
civilization as a recurring
theme in the western.
This kind of
recurring subject is
at the very heart of
what Westerns do and turn
the movies, I think, into
a particularly appropriate
environment for the
largeness and grandeur
that Westerns represent.
But that itself isn't
quite enough to explain
why the Westerns occupy
such a central place.
And of course, there are
historical and cultural
explanations as well.
The first explanation
is that the movies
are born at the end of a
period in which we could say
the real west actually existed.
In other words, the
movies come in just
at the moment-- the
movies actually are still
around when the experience
of what we call the West
was still historically actual.
It wasn't quite in the past.
The Western genre
is focused really
on a 30 year period, that
what some critics have
called the real west, in
the period from about 1860
through 1890.
And this is the period of the
Civil War, of a whole variety
of Indian wars, of the laying of
the transcontinental railroad,
of the California and
Dakota gold rushes,
the period of the range wars
I mentioned a little while ago
between settlers and
great ranchers who
wanted to keep spaces
open for their cattle.
And of course, we now
realize it's the period,
although the early Westerns
didn't want to acknowledge this
and told a kind
of opposite, it's
also of course the era
in which we exterminate,
virtually-- the era of genocide
against Native Americans,
the extermination of Indians
and of the Buffalo that
roamed the Western plains.
And before this real
west moment was over,
even before it
became history, it
had begun to be mythologized.
It was mythologized
in the popular culture
simultaneously with
its actual existence.
And there were a whole series
of forms of publication
and forms of drama that
drew on the west and stories
of the west and begin to
establish what we might call
the basic conventions
of the Western mythology
or the parable America
likes to tell itself
about the nature of
the settling the West.
One of these forms
were the dime novels
that appeared in the
late 19th century
and into the early 20th century,
available usually in paperback
at news stands.
And some of them were
immensely popular.
Here's one title,
a very famous one,
the equivalent of a
best seller, I guess,
of the day published in
1882-- The Life, Times,
and Treacherous Death
of Jesse James, 1882.
And of course, what
these dime novels
did was they took what were
quasi historical events,
sometimes real events, and
immensely elaborated them,
fictionized them into heroic
fables of various kinds,
often celebrating people
like Jesse James who
may well have been outlaws
and disreputable people
in actuality.
Another title-- The Illustrated
Lives and Adventures
of Frank and Jesse James
and the Younger Brothers.
And you can imagine what that
kind of thing would have done.
In addition to
these dime novels,
there will also stage
performances, plays.
They were often some form of
melodrama set in the Old West
and involving the basic costumes
and accoutrements of a Western,
right?
Pistols and cowboy hats and
school marms from the east
and so forth.
But perhaps even more important
than these two sources,
and they were very powerful
and important forms
of popular culture before films
to help establish what we might
call the mythology of the west,
were the Buffalo Bill shows,
the wild west shows.
These were unbelievably
popular and successful.
Here is a picture
of a kind of flyer
that would be distributed
in small towns
or sometimes in larger
towns as the Wild West show
and-- the Wild West
show came to town.
The star of the Wild West show
was William Cody, Buffalo Bill.
He had a very modest
actual career in the west.
But it was immensely elaborated
by him and his publicist
into something much grander
and more remarkable.
Buffalo Bill made his first
age appearance in 1872
in a stage melodrama called
"Scout of the Planes,"
which went on a two
year four, right?
And then in 1882,
10 years later,
he formed his own
wild west show, which
became immensely popular,
traveled all over the country,
and then made trips to Europe.
He even did one Wild West show
before the Queen of England.
And it was an immensely
successful public enactment.
The basic elements
of the wild west show
contained the essential
mythology that
then moved into the movies.
They often dramatized--
in the wild west show,
they often dramatize a
battle between white men
and Indians in which the
Indians were very treacherous
and were finally defeated.
They sometimes, in fact, in some
of the forms of the wild west
show, they reenacted the
Battle of Little Bighorn
in which at the last
minute, there was a rescue.
They reversed history
in it sometimes
in order to dramatize
an outcome that
was more appealing to
the white audiences.
The wild west show
staged battles
between cowboys and Indians.
And in fact, one of the
great historical ironies,
the historical irony
that the director we're
looking at next
week, Robert Altman,
actually picks up on in
one of his films called
"Buffalo Bill and the Indians,"
a film he made in the 1970s--
1975, I think.
One of the shocking things
is that at a certain point,
at least for two
years, I think, one
of the participants
in the Wild West shows
was Sitting Bull himself,
the defeated Indian,
the defeated Native American
leader who was now domesticated
and actually became
part of the show.
And in Altman's fictionalized
version of this episode,
a drunken Paul Newman
plays Buffalo Bill.
And he's mocked and made
fun of in some sense
by a character who represents
Chief Sitting Bull, who
has all the dignity-- he's
almost the only character
in the film with real dignity.
It's a subversive post
Hollywood era Western,
as you might guess.
So the Wild West shows, the
Buffalo Bill wild west shows,
were essentially
an early rehearsal
for what the movies became.
And many of the elements
of the wild west
show-- fancy roping,
fancy shooting,
conflicts between cowboys
and Indians, the performance
of various horse riding
tricks, herding of cattle
and so forth-- all sort of
contained the elements that
then moved into the
movies in an even more
systematic and powerful way.
And then I might mention
one final source--
the novel itself.
At the beginning of
the 20th century,
in 1902, one of the best selling
novels of all time in English
was published.
It was a book
called The Virginian
by a writer named
Owen Worcester.
And it remains one
of the bestselling
books in the history
of the United States.
It still sells thousands
of books every year.
I once found, in
a used bookstore,
an addition of
The Virginian that
had been published
I think 15 years
after its original publication.
And that addition was, I think,
the 50th addition of the book.
It went through an incredible
number of-- and in fact,
the addition I had also included
beautiful illustrations that
obviously were added
to later additions
once the popularity of
the book became known.
So what we find is that
the popular culture
before the advent of movies
had already, in some sense,
created a full fledged
mythology of the Western,
had familiarized the society
with the basic attitudes,
assumptions, costumes,
and fundamental archetypal
characters who
organize the Western.
And there's one further
thing to emphasize.
This may be the
most important thing
of all, what we might call
the intellectual culture.
It was-- not only was there
a real historical background
to the Western and
not only was there
a profound form of popular
culture in theater,
in public performances,
like these wild west shows,
and in dime novels as well
as in literary novels--
a tremendous
compost of discourse
that already sort of
establishes the genre even
before the movies arrive.
There was also a final touch.
And this is the thing that
helps to explain, I think,
maybe more powerfully than the
other examples I've given you
why the Western had such a
hold and continues in some ways
to have such a vestigial hold
on the American imagination
and on America's
sense of itself.
And that is what happens
in what I call here
the intellectual culture.
In 1893, one of the most famous
historians, Frederick Jackson
Turner, published an essay in
the American Historical Soci--
or delivered a lecture
and then it was later
published as an
essay-- delivered
a lecture to the American
Historical Society.
And the title of the essay
was "The Significance
of the Frontier in
American History."
it's probably the single most
influential historical essay
about the American past.
It's been attacked and
undermined and qualified
and its limitations have
been widely discussed
over the last 25 years.
But it still remains, in some
respects, a seminal essay,
even when historians are
reacting against it-- one
of the most important central
essays about the nature
of American culture.
And this article-- in this
article, Frederick Jackson
Turner argued
essentially that-- he
was trying to make
a case for what
makes the United States unique.
He was making a
case for what we now
call American exceptionalism,
a dubious proposition.
But let's listen
to his argument,
which has a good deal
of power and interest.
He said essentially
that the existence
of free land, of a continuously
receding settlement,
of a continuously receding
frontier, the advance
of settlement westward
with European settlers
always pressing
against that frontier,
that the existence of such
a reality in American life
had altered inherited notions
of social class and aristocratic
government and had created a
tendency toward what Turner
implied were or said
were the American ideals
of individualism
and classlessness,
of democracy itself.
In other words,
the United States,
according to Turner's
argument, had
a particularly open
and democratic feel
because the existence of
this frontier allowed people
to escape into a new life,
to find possibilities,
to escape the confinements
of social class,
even perhaps in some
small degree of gender,
although feminist
historians have certainly
shown how confining the life of
women in the west actually was.
Nonetheless, a sense that
the existence of the frontier
made the United States a
uniquely individualistic
and a uniquely free society.
What Turner had
done, of course, was
define a central historical
myth for European Americans,
for the white society
in the United States.
And we've come to recognize that
limitations of the argument.
What's the most profound,
obvious limitation
that occurs to you instantly?
How about the people
who already here, right?
In other words,
one of the things
that's wrong with
the Turner thesis
is that it's oblivious
to the existence
of the Native Americans
who were pushed aside
by the white settlers.
It's a very complex story and I
don't want to oversimplify it.
I don't mean that the
heroic white people who
got in the Conestoga
wagons and who
settled the west,
about whom there
are dozens if not hundreds if
not thousands of-- certainly
thousands if we count stories
in all formats-- of movies
and books and short stories
and plays and so forth.
I don't want to
suggest that there
was nothing heroic or
remarkable about that behavior.
There was.
The United States is not
wrong-- American culture is not
wrong in some sense to celebrate
the heroism of those people.
But of course, as
we've come to realize,
and as many of our most recent
Westerns openly acknowledge,
this original mythology
which sort of celebrated
unambiguously the white
settlement of the West
was actually also in
some sense an invasion
and even a genocide.
And the Turner thesis
doesn't even imagine that.
It sees it as a
triumphal reality.
So there were limits, terrible
limits, to the argument.
But there's also something
profoundly helpful
about the argument.
There is a sense
of spaciousness,
a sense of new possibilities,
a greater hostility
to social class and inherited
wealth in the United States
than there are in other places.
And for both good and
ill, the United States
celebrates forms
of individualism
as against communal behavior
with a kind of intensity
and compelling power that
many, many, not just Europeans,
that many, many non Americans
think is excessive and think
has been reflected in some
sense in various forms
of national behavior which we
needn't discuss in detail now.
But you could all imagine
your own examples.
But to come back to
the primary point,
then, one of the reasons that--
it's as if the movies were sort
of waiting for the Western,
as if the Western form already
in some sense, in fundamental
ways, fully formed
comes into the movies just
as the movies are born,
as if the format of the movies
and the content of the Western
were made for each
other in some sense.
And it becomes one of the
dominant, one of the signature
features of American cinema.
One of the fundamental aspects
of what the Western is,
if we think of it as a
kind of cultural mythology,
is that it tells
a founding story.
It tells the story
again and again.
It repeats it every time you
see a Western in some sense.
Every Western is
implicitly a story
about the foundation
of a society,
about the equation
of a community.
It's always implicitly about it.
In many Westerns, this
is an explicit topic.
And what we can say
is that this means
that the Western is the United
States' form of a kind of story
that every culture has, right?
The ancient Greeks had
a founding mythology
grounded in The Iliad
and The Odyssey, right?
And Tudor England had
a founding mythology
partly promulgated by
Shakespeare in the history
plays that were put on
in the public theater
in the 16th century.
And what we can say
about these founding
stories as they are always,
in some sense, fantasies
or fictions.
But they articulate
values and assumptions
that the culture,
in some sense, would
like to believe about itself.
And by their reiteration,
by their repetition,
by telling them
again and again, they
instantiate these values, these
assumptions about the society,
in the culture as a whole.
Their very repetition
is important.
Because one of the
fundamental things
about a myth or a mythology, one
of the most fundamental things
about it, is that
it's a collective--
it's a collective story.
It's not made by
a single person.
And one way to think
about all Westerns,
although of course many
of the best Westerns
have the trace of--
more than the traces--
have the imprint of
individual contributions.
John Ford-- John Ford
is a great director.
And there are aspects of
John Ford's personality
in every one of his Westerns.
Nonetheless, even the most
profoundly Fordian Western
is still a collaborative
form, not only
because Ford as a director--
because the movies
are inherently
collaborative because they
have so many different
people who contribute
to the creation of the whole.
No one, even the most
powerful director,
can completely
control everything.
The greatest directors
know how to collaborate
with their performance
and their writers.
But in any case, it's
a collaborative form
to begin with, right?
But there's another
kind of collaboration,
several other kinds.
What are they?
One of them is that every
Western is implicitly
in a conversation with
every previous Western.
And in that since,
there's no author.
It's a collective-- the story
of the American Western,
in that sense, is
a collective story.
It's a creation of the culture.
And in fact, every new
version of the Western
adds to the mythology
in some sense, right?
So in that sense, we can
think of genre reforms
generally, the
Western in particular,
as a particular kind of
ongoing, recurring discourse.
And if you come back again
to the arguments I was making
at the beginning of our
class about the ways in which
genre forms and
especially the Western
can be seen to sort of
dramatize cultural change
or the way in which a society's
attitudes may alter over time
exactly because so many
elements of a genre
are stable and recognizable,
those that are different
are easy to recognize, are
easy to identify and speculate
about.
So one of the things
we're recognizing here
is that in a certain sense, the
very fact that the mythology is
open, is unfinished,
reflects something that's
fundamental about society too.
And this is part of Raymond
Williams' great insight
into culture when
he said-- what he
said was culture is a constant
mix of emergent, traditional,
and dominant voices.
It's never over.
What culture is
is a conversation.
It's never any one fixed thing
because culture is always
in process.
It's always changing.
And what we can say-- the
value of these genre reforms,
and especially because the
movies could reach so widely,
even across linguistic barriers,
the value of the movies
or the power of the movies as a
form of this kind of discourse
is overwhelmingly clear
exactly because we
can imagine this process,
this conversation,
going on repeatedly over time--
the recognizable elements
juxtaposed against the elements
that are not recognizable,
allowing for a kind of constant
process of reevaluation,
of rehearsal, and of
rethinking, right?
And we can say, in
fact, that that's
one of the deep functions that
genre forms in general play
and it's one of the
central functions
that the Hollywood movie plays.
And I'll try to
concretize this for you
this evening in a kind of--
it's a kind of comic attempt,
but I'm going to give you
a kind of capsule history
of the trajectory of the
Western from its earliest days,
from "The Great Train
Robbery," to "Unforgiven."
So the Western is a mythology.
It's a mythology.
The fact that mythologies
themselves are open
ended, are spaces in which a
society defines and redefines
its identity and its central
values, makes the Western movie
a particularly powerful and
central anthropological space.
It enacts, in different
ways over and over again,
a story about the
founding of society.
And at the end, it
is grounded therefore
also in a series of
complex dichotomies
that are worth making
clear, even though they're
very obvious when you think
about what all Westerns do.
But think about them.
One of the dichotomies
is the dichotomy
between what is
thought to be civilized
and what is thought to be
savage-- between civilization
and savagery.
Another is often
between East and West
in which the east
represents civilization
and the west the sa-- but
there's an ambivalence.
Because the east is
also a place that
is thought to be dessicated
and lacking vitality.
And the west is thought to
be an authentic place that
tests us in our heroic,
largest possibilities, right?
And another kind of
dichotomy that is present
in virtually all Westerns is a
dichotomy between what we might
call the claims of community,
the claims of society
on the one side, and the
claims of the individual
on the other side, right?
This is a special
problem for the Western
because it celebrates American
individualism so powerfully.
The iconic scenes of
the Western in which
two men wearing guns square
off against each other
and the quicker one survives--
that scene of the quick draw
one and of the death
in the dusty street
could be sent to be a kind
of embodiment of these values
in which you have
to rely on yourself.
You can't rely on someone else.
You can't rely on
the government.
You can't rely on the Sheriff.
You can't rely on the police.
You can't rely on
your neighbors.
You have to trust yourself.
And in fact, one
of the ways you can
see the power of these
Western mythologies operating,
as it seems to me
in some sense, one
of the great divides in
the United States today
over the question of
guns and gun control
is partly grounded in these
myths of individualism
that the Western
mythology has been
promulgating since before
the advent of the movies.
In other words, the
attitudes-- and in fact,
if you listen to even some of
the most extreme forms of gun
rights advocates actually
talk in a language
that we can recognize from
Westerns, from Western movies.
Not an accident that one
of our recent presidents
was a star in Western films
and actually remembered
some films he'd been in as if
they'd been actual history.
And I don't say that in a
way to sort of disparage
poor Ronald Reagan at all,
but as a way of reminding us
the confluence or the
confusion of actual history
with these mythological
accounts of the west
is a characteristic feature
of the American imagination.
How could it be otherwise?
We have been so inundated in
these stories about the west.
So another dichotomy, then,
is that between society
and the individual,
maybe finally we
can say a dichotomy between
culture and nature, right?
Which is the story that's
enacted again and again
in the great epic stories that
every culture sort of generates
for itself.
One of the most distinctive
features of these dichotomies
is the divided hero,
a character you'll
see embodied with great
complexity in tonight's film
played by John Wayne,
a character who
is-- the Western hero is
often seen very ambivalently
as both a savior and a savage,
as someone who has the power
and authority to bring a kind
of decency and lawfulness
to a community, but who
is himself so touched by,
so tainted by the very
savagery that he tried
to tame, that he's often
excluded from the community
once it's been created.
And you'll see a wonderful
instance, a complex instance
of that, in tonight's film
in the way the John Wayne
character, at the
very end of the film,
is in a certain sense
excluded from the community
that he has helped to defend.
One way to see many
of these things
or to clarify many
is to juxtapose--
or maybe as a way
of crystallizing this process
I'm talking about whereby
a genre form can, in some sense,
dramatize changing values.
I want to show you one scene.
Maybe I'll just
end with the scene.
This is a scene from
"McCabe and Mrs. Miller",
the film you're going to see
in two weeks, a Western that
comes after the breakdown
of the Hollywood system,
after the movies no longer
have the responsibility
or the obligation-- no
longer saw themselves
as having to speak to
everyone-- a moment of great,
in many ways, extraordinary
artistic freedom,
the period of the late '60s
and through a good part
of the 1970s.
Many people would say it was
a moment in American cinema
unrivaled for its
complexity and its richness.
And one of the reasons
it was such a rich moment
was that the movies
had been liberated
from their responsibility to
talk to the whole culture.
There was an irony connected
to that because they
have smaller audience.
But it gave them a kind
of political freedom,
a kind of moral freedom
that they hadn't had before.
And I want to show
you one scene.
One reason I'm choosing
it is because it
will resonate for you when
we come to "McCabe and Mrs.
Miller."
But it requires that
you know one thing.
The scene, the iconic scene
that I mentioned earlier
where two heroes or
one hero and a bad guy
square off against each other
on a dusty street to draw a gun
might be said to be the
most recurring or the most--
the quintessential
Western scene,
although there are
others we might nominate
as almost as important.
And in order to understand
the scene you're about to see,
you need to recognize
that what lies
behind this very subversive
version of the shoot out
are dozens, if not
hundreds, of earlier
scenes in which heroic
characters that we greatly
admire shoot down bad
guys in the street, right?
Well, here's a scene
from "McCabe and Mrs.
Miller" of this iconic moment.
Remember, "McCabe
and Mrs. Miller"
comes after the
consensus dispensation.
It's free not to be
a consensus form.
But one reason I
want to show you
this is I hope you can
recognize that what
gives this scene its
power is not-- it's
very brilliantly
photographed and dramatized.
But what gives it its
power has very little
to do with what it itself does.
What grants its
enormous authority
are the dozens, if not hundreds,
of prior scenes with which it's
in conversation, against which
it is contrasting itself.
Because this scene
of confrontation
between two individuals--
who has the faster gun,
right-- is, as I've
suggested, the iconic moment
in the Western.
And it is, in the
heroic Western,
in the traditional Western,
it's a heroic moment
of individual self assertion
in which good conquers evil.
Watch Robert Altman's
version of this.
WOMAN: Careful.
Come back.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[? -There's ?] shorty!
[INAUDIBLE]
[DOG WHINING]
[CLINKING]
[GUNSHOT]
-I wasn't trying to hit it.
The trick is not to hit
it, but to make it float.
PROFESSOR: He's lying.
You're supposed to
realize he's lying here.
He meant to hit it.
Here comes the cowboy
who's just [INAUDIBLE].
All the prostitutes loved you.
-Hey, hold it, sonny.
-What?
-Hold up on your target
practice a minute.
I don't want to get shot.
-Well, then get off the
bridge, you saddle tramp.
-I want to buy some socks.
I got a long ride ahead of me.
-What's wrong with
the socks you got on?
-I wore them out running
around half-naked
in that whorehouse over there.
Actually quite a place.
You been there yet?
-Take off your
boots and show me.
-You're joshing me.
-I said, take off your boots,
and show me, eh, sucker?
-I ain't going to do that.
-What are you
wearing that gun for?
-[INAUDIBLE] I just wear it.
Can't hit nothing with it.
-Well, that don't make no sense.
What kind of a gun is it?
-Colt.
-Them's big guns.
That's what I got.
Must be something wrong with it.
-Naw, it's me.
I just can't shoot good.
-Well, let me see it.
Come on.
Maybe I can fix it for you.
-OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
[END PLAYBACK]
BOY: So what the scene--
what the scene does
is it turns on its
head what we might say
are the central
values or assumptions
that have lain
behind such a seen
in dozens, if not hundreds,
of prior Westerns.
And that's a distilled
example of this process
of a conversation that
goes on-- if it goes on
for a long enough time, the
content of the conversation
can virtually reverse itself
even though the genre remains
stable.
And that's one of
the-- we might call
that the genius of genre,
the genius of a genre form.
It has to do with--
it's a version of what
I mean when I talk
about the cultural work
or the anthropological
function that movies have.